♪ ♪ ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
THE NEWS IS MOVING WITH
BEWILDERING SPEED IN CASE YOU
HAVEN’T NOTICED.
NO ONE HAS EVER CHANGED SO MANY
BASIC INSTITUTION FACTS OF
AMERICAN LIFE AND DONE IT SO
QUICKLY.
WE BRING YOU NIGHTLY UPDATES FOR
THE WEEK AND A HALF IN WHICH
BIDEN HAS BEEN PRESIDENT.
IT IS OVERWHELMING.
THERE ARE SO MUCH TO COVER.
WE LEARNED THAT THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO MAKE THE
TINY DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA ARE
51ST STATE.
A MORE CORRUPT ENGLISH-SPEAKING
VERSION OF MONACO.
AS IF LOBBYISTS DIDN’T HAVE
ENOUGH CONTROL.
BUT THAT IS NOT EVEN THE BIGGEST
NEWS.
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO, BIDEN
OFFICIALS INFORMED US THAT AFTER
ALMOST 65 YEARS OF WORKING TO
BUILD A NUCLEAR WEAPON, THE
NATION OF IRAN "JUST WEEKS AWAY
FROM GETTING A BOMB."
AFTER 65 YEARS OF TRYING.
YOU ARTY KNOW HOW THAT STORY IS
GOING TO END.
TRILLIONS SPENT, MANY DEAD.
THE UNITED STATES GAINING
NOTHING.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT A LOT AND IT’S
HAPPENING AGAIN.
JOE BIDEN JUST SENT AMERICAN
TROOPS TO SYRIA.
YOU DIDN’T KNOW THAT?
YEP.
HOURS AFTER HE BECAME PRESIDENT,
AMERICAN SOLDIERS CROSSED INTO
THE NATION OF SYRIA HERE AND
SENDING THEM TO SYRIA WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS JOE BIDEN DID.
SOME IN THE MEDIA FORGOT TO EVEN
MENTION THAT.
IN THEIR DEFENSE, AS NOTED,
THERE’S A LOT GOING ON IN THE
NEWS, INCLUDING A LOT OF TROOP
MOBILIZATION.
SYRIA IS NOT THE ONLY PLACE.
WASHINGTON, D.C., LOOKS LIKE
OCCUPIED --
A SMALL CITY OVERFLOWING WITH
SOLDIERS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TROOPS, WE
ARE TOLD THEY ARE GOING TO
PROTECT THE CAPITAL FOR THE
INEVITABLE WHITE BRING TO RIGHT
VIOLENCE.
JOE BIDEN WAS INAUGURATED AND
THERE WASN’T ANY VIOLENCE.
TRUMP VOTERS DIDN’T RUSH.
THE TRUMP RESTORATION NEVER
HAPPENED.
AND YET THE TROOP STAYED.
NO ONE IN CONGRESS SEEMED TO
NOTICE BUT IN FACT THEY ARE
STILL ARRIVING.
THOUSANDS OF THEM AS OF LAST
THURSDAY.
THAT NUMBER SEEMS TO HAVE RISEN
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS.
WE CALLED THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
FIND OUT BY HOW MUCH BUT THEY
COULDN’T GIVE US AN ANSWER.
WE DO KNOW THAT MORE STATES HAVE
SENT TROOPS SINCE LAST WEEK.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THE VIDEO OF
SOLDIERS GETTING OFF BUSES
DOWNTOWN NEAR THE CAPITAL.
ONE OF THE ALL DOING THEIR?
AGAIN, NATIONAL GUARD LEADERSHIP
WHEN IT TELL US.
"FOR OPERATIONAL SECURITY
REASONS WE WILL NOT GET INTO
SPECIFIC DETAILS OF THE ONGOING
MISSION."
OH, SOLDIERS IN OUR CAPITAL BUT
WE DON’T HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHY.
THE GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS WAS NOT
SO SHY.
HE LAID IT OUT VERY CLEARLY.
IN A PRESS RELEASE ANNOUNCING
THE DEPLOYMENT OF MORE SOLDIERS
TO WASHINGTON TO SEE, HE
EXPLAINED THAT "WE MUST ROOT OUT
THE DARK FORCES OF RACISM, WHITE
SUPREMACY, AND DISINFORMATION
THAT HAVE CREATED THIS MOMENT.
"THE MILITARY HAS BEEN DEPLOYED
TO WASHINGTON, D.C., TO FIGHT
DISINFORMATION.
SO, SAY SOMETHING A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR DOESN’T LIKE AND HE
WILL SEND TROOPS.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE THE COUNTRY
THAT YOU GREW UP IN?
IT PROBABLY DOESN’T.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY THINGS ARE
DONE IN AMERICA.
IT’S NOT THE WAY IT HAS BEEN
DONE SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
NO ONE HAS EVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
SO, WHY IS EVERYONE, EVERYONE
PRETENDING THAT IT IS TOTALLY
NORMAL TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF
TROOPS IN THE CAPITAL TO FIGHT
DISINFORMATION?
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE IN
FAVOR OF IT.
THEY THINK IT IS FINE TO
MOBILIZE THE ARMY IN ORDER TO
PUT DOWN DOMESTIC OPINION.
MSNBC, LET US REMIND YOU, AND
OPINION CHANNEL, IS CLEARLY IN
FAVOR OF THIS.
WATCH.
>> AND NOW 5,000 NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS WILL BE DEPLOYED THROUGH
MARCH.
EXTREMISM RESEARCHERS SAY THAT
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
POSSIBLE VIOLENCE SURROUNDING
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
>> THE NATIONAL GUARD WILL HAVE
TO SAY THERE IS A SYMBOL TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO THINK THAT THE
BUILDING IS VULNERABLE.
THAT INCLUDES THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO WENT UP THERE AND
PERFORMED INSURRECTION.
>> INSIDE THE PENTAGON’S
DECISION TO KICK THOUSANDS OF
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS IN THE
STREETS OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE GREATEST THREAT FACING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT IS ALREADY
AMONG US.
>> Tucker: OH, EXTREMISM
RESEARCHERS.
SO, THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER IS NOW IN CHARGE OF
THE PENTAGON.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
THE WHOLE THING, GOT PUNCHED, BY
THE WAY, THEY JUST TOLD YOU.
THEY HAVE ORDERED UP AN
UNSPECIFIED NUMBER OF SOLDIERS
FOR AN UNSPECIFIED PERIOD OF
TIME.
THAT IS NOT A GUT PUNCH.
IT IS BUSINESS AS USUAL.
GUT PUNCH IS AND THE FACT IS,
AND IT DEFINITELY IS A FACT.
IT IS NOT RWANDA LEVEL
PROPAGANDA.
THE FACT IS THAT THE GREATEST
THREAT FACING THE EMERGENT
PEOPLE IS ALREADY AMONG US.
ALREADY AMONG US.
THEY ARE HERE.
TERRIFIED YET?
THE WOMAN YOU JUST SAW ON
TELEVISION, SHE WENT TO HARVARD.
IT’S NOT LIKE SHE WAS READING
FROM A PRESS RELEASE ISSUED BY
SOME CREEPY AUTHORITARIAN.
NO, NOT AT ALL.
SHE KNOWS WHO THE ENEMY IS AND
THIS WEEK THE ENEMY WAS A
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN FROM 14TH
DISTRICT OF CONGRESS, FLORIDA.
NO WOMAN IS MORE DANGEROUS THAN
THIS FRESHMAN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
THE THREAT THAT SHE ALONE POSES
AS THEY SAY ON CABLE NEWS IS X
ESSENTIAL.
THIS SINGLE CONGRESSWOMAN MAY BE
JUST WEEKS AWAY FROM DEVELOPING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IF YOU WATCH TELEVISION THIS
WEEKEND, YOU ALREADY KNOW QUITE
A BIT ABOUT HER.
>> HE HAS ALSO BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH FLORIDA CONGRESSWOMAN AND
QANON’S MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
BECAUSE SHE HAS SPENT THE
WEEKEND SCRUBBING HER
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT.
THE COPEOPLE ARE SPREADING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND DOUBLING
DOWN ON INCITING VIOLENCE.
THAT OF COURSE IS MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE.
>> MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, WHO
HAS BEEN IN THE NEWS THIS ENTIRE
WEEKEND IS A CONSPIRACY THEORIST
THEORIST.
>> Tucker: OH.
HOW DANGEROUS IS THIS THREE
NAMED CONGRESSWOMAN YOU HAVE
PROBABLY NEVER HEARD OF?
IN THE NAME OF DEMOCRACY, SHE
MUST BE EXPELLED TONIGHT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
THE MEMBER IN QUESTION WAS
ELECTED AT A 75 VOTE.
THAT IS ROUGHLY THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF THE VOTE THAT
NANCY PELOSI GOT OUT.
SO THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT HER
VOTERS VERY MUCH WANTED HER TO
REPRESENT THEM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WHAT TO HER
VOTERS HAVE TO DO WITH
DEMOCRACY?
THAT IS NOT HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
CNN GETS A VETO.
THE TEST IS ENTIRELY IDEOLOGICAL
IDEOLOGICAL.
THIS NEW MEMBER OF CONGRESS HAS
BARELY BEEN VOTED.
SHE JUST GOT THERE THE OTHER
DAY.
BUT CNN SAYS SHE HAS BAD
OPINIONS.
THEREFORE SHE IS THE GREATEST
THREAT WE FACE.
OUR ADVICE IS KEEP IT TO
YOURSELF.
ANYONE WHO SUGGESTS THAT THIS
MEMBER OF CONGRESS IS NOT REALLY
AMERICA’S GREATEST ENEMY IS BY
DEFINITION ONE OF THE GREATEST
ENEMIES.
WHEN THE PEOPLE OF CNN DON’T
AGREE WITH
THE PROGRAM.
THEY ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
THEY ARE CHILDREN, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN THEY
WON’T WIN IN THE END OR IT WON’T
GET WORSE.
WHY?
DONALD TRUMP IS GONE NOW.
THAT IS VERY BAD NEWS FOR THE
MANY PEOPLE WHO MADE HIS LIVING
YELLING AT DONALD TRUMP.
AND IT’S ESPECIALLY DANGEROUS
FOR THE POLITICAL PARTY.
A PARTY WHO IS NONSENSICAL AND
CAN ONLY HANG TOGETHER LIKE
COLLECTIVELY THROWING ROCKS, AS
YOU MENTIONED HAPPENS TO BE IN
THE CENTER OF THE HATE CIRCLE
TODAY.
THERE’S NO MORE DONALD TRUMP,
THAT MEANS YOU GET TO BE
DONALD TRUMP NOW.
SEE HOW THAT FEELS.
IT’S ALL PRETTY PREDICTABLE.
YOU COULD HAVE WRITTEN THE
SCRIPT.
THE SAD THING IS THEY ARE
MISSING A LOT.
THIS IS THE MEDIA AFTER ALL.
THEIR JOB IS TO COVER THE NEWS.
THERE’S TONS OF INTERESTING
THINGS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW,
THINGS YOU TEND TO MISS WHEN YOU
SPEND ALL DAY SCREAMING ABOUT A
SINGLE MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE POPULAR REVOLT
UNDERWAY ON WALL STREET.
THAT IS NOT A SMALL STORY.
WHAT BEGAN AS AN ATTACK ON A
SHORT SELLER WILL LIKELY CHANGE
OUR ECONOMY PERMANENTLY AND
FOREVER.
SO WHY ARE AT THE RADDATZ GUYS
DOING THIS IN THE FIRST PLACE?
WOULDN’T IT BE NICE IF SOMEONE
SOMEWHERE HAD ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE REDDIT
GUYS HAVE A POINT, NO MATTER HOW
DESTRUCTIVE THEIR TACTICS MAY
BE.
IT COULD BE THAT COVID
ACCELERATED THE CONCENTRATION OF
WEALTH IN THIS COUNTRY TO A
DEGREE THAT IS DANGEROUS AND
COMPLETELY UNSUSTAINABLE, THAT
THIS WAS A REACTION TO IT.
BUT BECAUSE CORPORATIONS HAVE
MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANYONE TO
SAY ANYTHING TRUE OUT LOUD
ANYMORE, LIKE HEY, HEDGE FUNDS
AREN’T ACTUALLY GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY.
OR WOW, WHY DON’T WE HAVE
SOMETHING IN OUR TAX CODE,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN’T SAY ANY OF
THAT IN PUBLIC NOW BEING CALLED
A RACIST BY SOME GOON FROM THE
HR DEPARTMENT DOWN THE HALL.
THE REDDIT GUYS MAY BE DIDN’T
HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO EXPRESS
THEIR FRUSTRATION AND INSTEAD
TOOK IT OUT ON THE PUBLIC
MARKET.
COULD THAT HAVE HAPPENED?
TOTALLY POSSIBLE.
THAT SEGMENT WAS NOT ON CABLE
NEWS THIS WEEK.
NOR WAS ANY SPECULATION ABOUT
HOW LONG A MARKET THAT IS THIS
DISCONNECTED FROM REALITY CAN
CONTINUE.
HOW LONG BEFORE THE WHOLE THING
CRASHES, NOT JUST THE STOCK
MARKET, BUT ANY SOCIETY BUILT
ONLINE.
HOW LONG BEFORE THE FLIMSIEST
EMBLEM EVER CREATED, AND WE
RETURNED TO THE REAL THING.
PHYSICS, GRAVITY, REASON, GOD.
HOW LONG?
ANY TIME?
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD QUESTIONS.
NONE HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED LATELY
IN THE MEDIA.
WE SIMPLY SAW "NEWSWEEK" FRET
ABOUT THE "FAR RIGHT EXTREMISTS
USING REDDIT TO MOK AREN’T NOBLE
FUNDS."
BETWEEN WHAT’S HAPPENING ON
WALL STREET RIGHT NOW AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEY WERE APPALLED WHEN THE
HEDGE FUNDS TAKE A HIT, IT’S MOB
RULE.
EVEN THE CORPORATE COMEDIANS
WEIGHED IN BOWING BEFORE THEIR
MASTERS IN FINANCE.
WATCH THIS GUY TELL YOU THAT IT
MUST HAVE BEEN THE RUSSIANS
DOING THIS.
NO DECENT, LOYAL AMERICAN WOULD
HURT A HEDGE FUND.
AND FOR ONCE, HE’S NOT JOKING.
>> THEIR STOCK PRICE HAS GROWN
BY 8000%, BECAUSE A BUNCH OF
AMATEUR INVESTORS MAY BE EVEN
SOME RUSSIAN DISRUPTORS PART OF
A REDDIT COMMUNITY DECIDED TO
BUY A BUNCH OF GAME STOP STOCK
AND DRIVE THE PRICE UP AND SCREW
OVER THE HEDGE FUND GUYS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU MUST BE
RUSSIAN.